For this quiz, the goal is to see that you
understand how to define a dictionary. You should define a dictionary
and assign it to the variable population, and it should
provide information on the world's largest cities. The key values in
your dictionary should be names, the name of each city.
And the associated value is the city's population in millions. So
that's a number. To get you started, here are the four
cities that your dictionary should
include. Shanghai's population of 17.8 million,
Istanbul with 13.3 million, Karachi, 13.0, and Mumbai with
12.5. If you don't happen to live in one
of those four cities, you might want to also include
your hometown and any other cities that you're interested
in. If you define your dictionary correctly, you should
be able to use it like this. Print the
population, indexing, looking up the value associated with the
key Mumbai, and you should get as output 12.5.